[Music]
what does 87 cents have to do with a
multi-million euro election campaign
what are companies like these doing at
political party events
and how come this neo-nazi party is
getting funding from the german state
it's all to do with the way political
parties are financed in germany
the general principles of
this party regulation and financial
regulation i think they're fair or at
least they're well intended but we have
seen in the past that there have been
many loopholes and that the system could
be manipulated
in germany there's no limit on how much
parties can spend on election
campaigning
but some parties have more to spend than
others
here's how the disparity looked at the
last federal election in 2017.
you can clearly see the two biggest
parties the christian democrats and the
social democrats spent at least triple
the amount of the smaller parties
to fully understand this let's go back
to the coins because this is about
counting every cent
these are the key sources of funding for
german political parties membership fees
fees paid by mps
donations other sources like sponsoring
assets shares publications and events
and then there's the big one
state funding
this system is supposed to make party
financing fair transparent and give
parties equal opportunity
and this is how it works
the more votes a party gets the more
public money it gets
public support is measured by three
things votes membership fees and
donations
for every voter party gets it also gets
87 cents from the state
for the first 4 million votes the figure
is even a little more 1 euro 6 cents per
vote
then for every euro a party gets in
membership fees it also gets 45 cents
from the state
this 45 cents per euro rule also applies
for personal donations
donations from people not the ones from
companies
but there are regulations
you can only get these 45 cents for
donations up to 3 300 euros per person
per
year and there's a limit for the total
amount of state financing
in 2021 this limit was set at 200
million 49
468 euros
smaller parties benefit from this system
too
they might have fewer supporters but
they still collect votes membership fees
and donations and according to what
we've just learned this means they get
money from the state
here's an example
last year the neo-nazi party npd got 370
632 euros 85 cents from the german state
it's a very small amount compared to
what the larger parties are getting but
a lot of germans aren't happy about it
because the npd has been ruled as
anti-constitutional
there is a push to stop public money
going to the npd
the government has asked the country's
top court to stop state funding flowing
to the extreme right
but the court doesn't seem to be in a
big hurry that was in 2019 and we're
still waiting for the verdict
that's one problem in the system but
critics highlight other loopholes
there's a lack of transparency there is
no
limit
to financial influence for example so
donations to political parties so
there's there's no legal maximum
indeed in germany there's no limit on
the amount parties can accept in
donations
to understand it better let's have a
look at the details there are different
transparency rules for small
medium and large donations
donations under 500 euros can stay
anonymous
if donations are more than 10 000 euros
parties have to publicly declare where
they come from they do this in their
annual reports
the problem here however is that the
reports usually appear with a very long
delay of one to two years
only donations over 50 000 euros have to
be declared immediately
another loophole in the system has to do
with these guys here and plenty of other
industry players and business
representatives
instead of making large donations big
companies often sponsor party events
instead
for example a car manufacturer
displaying products at a party
conference where they can also network
with politicians
sponsoring doesn't have to be declared
in the party's financial reports
and this is uh
it's really annoying and from my
perspective that sponsoring activity is
still
buried in this income from other
activities category in the annual
reports of parties and that means it is
invisible
put differently in transparent
that brings us to another issue the
authority that's supposed to check if
parties are sticking to the rules and
find them if not
critics say that body is not fit for
purpose
for example it cannot proactively
investigate parties
and it's also under the control of the
bundestag president who belongs to a
political party himself in the current
government the bundestag president is a
member of angela merkel's christian
democrats
so there's potential for conflict of
interest
what we need is simply
ameliorating the system as it is
rendering the supervisory body more
independent from politics
and
recognizing that donations at least
above 10 000 euro can really make an
impact and so
rendering donner's identity
transparent immediately
a look at the details makes it clear
there are many loopholes in the system
and experts say addressing these would
make party financing fairer
but for this year's election it's too
late for any changes
right now what matters to parties and
their bank accounts is getting as many
votes as possible on september 26th
because the scents really do add up